[Music]
on this Sunday night the federal plan to
flatten the curve in the cove in
nineteen pandemic reiterating the need
to limit travel and self isolate during
this health crisis this is our chance
right here right now the prime minister
says nothing is off the table to slow
the spread some Canadian schools are
extending Spring Break to contain Cova
19 but it's not consistent across the
country millions owed to those who serve
this country it's not fair to veterans
where is the money going and the inside
look at sex trafficking in Canada a
survivor story
[Music]
global national with Robin Gil
good evening and thank you for joining
us
Canadians are bracing for a dramatic
change in everyday life as the Week
starts with schools daycares and some
businesses closed in many parts of the
country it's an effort to limit the
impact of the global kovat 19 pandemic
and protect those who are vulnerable to
the new coronavirus but the numbers in
Canada keep rising there are more than
300 cases of Kovan 19 across the country
and as of today it's in all provinces
with Nova Scotia announcing its first
three presumptive cases they're all
related to travel but the outbreak is
hitting Ontario the hardest with more
than 40 new cases since yesterday
bringing the total in that province to
at least 145 just five of the provinces
cases have been resolved so far but
while other countries including the
United States have declared a national
emergency the head of Canada's public
health agency says there's no need to do
that here some of the others are the
declarations that you seen in other
countries are for them to seek
additional authorities which could be
financial these are the federal level we
already have the necessary tools and
mechanisms and authorities to obtain the
kind of funding and other authorities
that we we need but dr. Tam is
reiterating the call for Canadians to
postpone or cancel any international
travel
WestJet says two passengers on two
recent flights tested positive for Kovan
19 one passenger was on a flight from
Vancouver to Kelowna on March 10th the
other was on a flight from London
Gatwick to Toronto Pearson on March 11th
that fear has fewer people traveling
anyway which will likely lead Airlines
to cut flights now the rush is on to get
Canadians already outside of the country
home before travel becomes more
difficult
here's Abigail Beeman that was my
concern I didn't want to when the
borders are closed now
after being told by Ottawa to get back
while you still can
airports are busy with returning
Canadians nerves on high Elliot Maggs
witnessed a fight in the customs line
someone had you know bumped into someone
else and then the other guy said what
are you doing he had a face mask on
calling Koba 19 a serious public health
threat the country's top doctor is now
asking Canadians returning from anywhere
to self isolate for 14 days with cases
rapidly increasing in Canada
particularly in British Columbia Ontario
and Alberta a window to flatten the
curve of the epidemic is narrow we're
all being very very careful and Justin
Trudeau is holding a rare Sunday cabinet
meeting speaking from outside his home
where he is self isolating in an
interview with ctv's question period the
Prime Minister addressed whether it's
time to close the border we have taken
some very strong measures and we are not
taking anything off the table we are
looking daily at next steps that we
might take or we should take and those
conversations continue I don't know how
I'm gonna survive out here if I can't
get home meanwhile plenty of Canadians
feel stuck overseas jordan de l'arche
teaches English in France he has a
flight home booked for the end of March
trying to come home earlier seems
impossible there's certainly no flights
within the next four days and then
you'll find one flight that's around
four thousand dollars for first class
and then no more flights and then
another one $6,000 while this BC couple
has been on a cruise for two weeks and
tells global news they're currently
stuck at sea with other Canadians Chile
won't let them dock we have more evening
from and I guess we just have to wait
get on it or not air passenger rights
advocate gap or Lu catch calls it a dire
situation challenge people are going to
face is that there will be no flights
back there's been no talk of what
happens for Canadians stranded who tried
to come home while Canada's top doctor
says declaring a national emergency
isn't necessary in this country as
has the tools it needs to deal with the
situation for now Abigail Beeman global
news Ottawa the push to contain this
virus continues among the provinces
today Quebec Premier ordered all bars
movie theaters gyms and ski hills to
close Alberta
Nova Scotia and PEI are the latest
provinces to announce school closures
officials say these tough measures are
required to keep people safe
Heather York's West reports I just have
to take it day by day I guess 10 year
old marigold meok will be doing her
school work from home this week after
Alberta's premier announced tough new
measures to control the spread of kovat
19 these include the immediate
cancellation of all k12 and
post-secondary classes as well as
closure of licensed childcare and
out-of-school care programs in Alberta
schools and daycare centers will remain
closed after March break for at least
two weeks and we will continue to review
and consultation with public health
that means classes are now cancelled
across Manitoba Ontario Quebec nova
scotia Pei and Alberta school remains
open in Saskatchewan for now if you have
school closures that has a dynamo effect
you know parents may have to make
arrangements
either to stay home themselves or they
make arrangements for that may be worse
than being in the school setting
Comex premier has also ordered all
nightclubs bars and movie theaters
closed in his province restaurants can
remain open but only if they stay less
than 50% full why do we do that we do
that because we think that right now we
have to slow the increase in the number
of people infected so that's why we're
asking for these additional measures how
many pages to pack in Calgary this
mother thinks her province is doing the
right thing she and her daughter plan to
remain at home as much as possible right
now willing to do all they can to curb
the spread of kovin 19 Heather your ex
West Global News Calgary here's a look
at some of the consequences of this
outbreak on businesses Ontario is
closing all casinos effective today and
isn't saying when they'll reopen Mirvish
theaters suspended perform
until April 12th Whistler Blackcomb
Canada's largest ski resort has shut
down for a week another ski resort Mont
Tremblant has closed until further
notice
sportswear giant Nike is closing stores
in Canada to limit the spread and
Cadillac Fairview the company behind 19
shopping malls in Canada is reducing
ours
they'll be open from 11 a.m. to 7 p.m.
at least two provinces are limiting
testing for covin 19 health officials in
Ontario MVC say the sickest patients are
the priority and those who have not
traveled outside of Canada but are
showing symptoms the provinces are
trying to conserve supplies and ensure
the healthcare system has the capacity
to continue testing as numbers escalate
America's Federal Reserve swept into
action today slashing its benchmark
interest rate to near zero in a bid to
save the US economy the Reserve is
trying to encourage lending to offset
the impact of the outbreak Travel is
taking a hit and so many Americans are
scrambling to get home before they get
stranded they're being funneled into 13
airports to be screened so far 62 people
have died in the u.s. from Kovan 19 and
there are more than 3,000 confirmed
cases but as more people return from
abroad that could change here's Jennifer
Johnson shoulder to shoulder no social
distancing at US airports as Americans
returning from Europe are forced to wait
hours to be screened for kovat 19
Canadian travelers - coming from the
u.s. concerned about what they'll face
when they get home I'm anxious about
what awaits me when I get back to Canada
just as my arrival time gets later and
later in the day I'm worried about long
lines at YVR for customs and worried
that they're not going to have
appropriate measures in place they're
two separate people for social
distancing complicating the chaotic
situation a handful of TSA officers are
now testing positive for the virus
federal officials are working to get
more staff to speed up the testing
process but local officials are furious
hundreds and hundreds of people and
that's exactly what you don't want in
this pandemic
a nation's top infectious disease doctor
raising the possibility of a 14 day
nationwide lockdown to keep people home
out of restaurants bars movie theaters
and other public places but I think we
should really be overly aggressive and
get criticized for overreacting
dr. Fauci says there are no plans yet
for domestic travel restrictions but
warned everything is on the table with
limited testing available many experts
question whether the number of reported
cases of Coppa 19 in the US is accurate
the White House promising millions more
tests will be available soon we will now
have access in the days ahead to more
than 2,000 labs across the country that
have the equipment today to process
coronavirus tests much more rapidly and
a much higher volume New York's governor
is now calling on President Trump to
activate the military immediately to
help build more makeshift medical
facilities use them to come in right now
identify existing facilities that can be
retrofitted and use them to do it
Ohio is now closing all bars and
restaurants indefinitely empty pews
Sunday at Washington's famed National
Cathedral Times Square is quiet
desperate measures taken across the
country to keep people home meanwhile
the White House has announced that
President Trump has tested negative for
the virus after being exposed to people
who had tested positive Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington
Kovach 19 has killed more than 6,000
people around the world as cases spiked
some countries are taking radical action
by closing borders and imposing
mandatory quarantines on anyone arriving
from overseas Britain's health secretary
Matt Hancock confirmed today that
measures similar to ones used during
wartime will soon be imposed across the
UK anyone over 70 years old will be told
to stay inside potentially for months
carmakers will be told to produce
medical equipment and hotels will be
turned into hospitals we are going to
take the powers to make sure that we can
quarantine people if they are a risk to
public health yes and that's important
and take
other action that you just normally
wouldn't meanwhile Denmark closed its
borders yesterday to everyone except its
citizens and residents Germany is set to
follow suit shutting borders with France
Switzerland and Austria the Czech
Republic which has already closed its
borders is now weighing a nationwide
quarantine and in Australia anyone
arriving will now be forced to self
isolate for 14 days and foreign cruise
ships are banned from docking in that
country Italy suffered its most deaths
in a single day 368 people died in that
country in just 24 hours
Spain is the second hardest hit country
in Europe with 289 deaths and almost
8,000 confirmed cases the government is
using drones to tell its citizens to
stay indoors they can only go out to buy
food and medicine all social gatherings
are banned the health official leading
iran's response to kovat 19 today
acknowledged the pandemic could
overwhelm hospitals there Iran is
already building mass graves to bury the
dead and is the worst affected country
in the Middle East 724 people are dead
and nearly 14,000 are infected
today Iran's Ministry of Health
confirmed 113 people died in 24 hours
its highest daily death toll since the
virus took hold and the other 1,200
cases have been confirmed but there are
still questions about the true scope of
the outbreak Cova 19 is also spreading
across africa 24 of the continents 54
countries now have confirmed cases
health officials say all cases were
brought by overseas travelers we know
you have lots of questions about the
virus our Jeff simple will consult with
experts and try to answer them so email
us at your questions at global news dot
CA and our website has a special page
dedicated entirely to the new corona
virus coming up millions of dollars are
earmarked for Canadian veterans so why
aren't they see
the benefits
the federal government promised to take
care of veterans as they transition out
of military service but new information
obtained by global news shows the
Department of Veterans Affairs isn't
spending all of the money it has
budgeted for services instead hundreds
of millions of dollars are going back
into government coffers my clicker tour
explains the impact on those who've
served this country it's clear how much
these animals and this farm mean - Blair
Davis in fact his wife says it's been a
lifesaver for the former soldier it
gives me the security to know that I
know where he is at all times that he
can't just walk out the door walk down
the street and and decide to get hit by
a truck and kill himself Davis's PTSD
was so bad he wanted to die the part of
the struggle was it took years for
Veterans Affairs Canada to acknowledge
his mental health concerns including
that his post-traumatic stress disorder
was linked to a 1993 peacekeeping
mission in Bosnia or the horrors of war
scarred him the wall had a picture of
the unicorn and flowers
and it was a little girl's room and it
was all blowing up all around but is
this you could sense that a little girl
live there and it was hard the battle
he's waging now is against his own
country in order to get health services
from Veterans Affairs Canada according
to the department only one-third of
veterans disability cases are processed
within their stated goal of 16 weeks
officials say the average time is 32
weeks yet hundreds of millions of
dollars earmarked for veterans are going
unspent each year and are returned into
government coffers mr. Regan mr. Riggins
dressage and in 2018 the House of
Commons voted unanimously to carry
forward unspent money for the sole
purpose of improving services however in
the 2018-2019 fiscal year the liberals
let 105 million dollars meant for
veterans go unspent it's not fair to
veterans and it is a direct via their
contradiction to what the Prime Minister
of Canada
promised veterans not only this mandate
but the last mandate ablaze says
legislation should be changed to hold
the government to its promise but that's
not necessary according to the
government
adding Veterans Affairs can access
unspent funds for the next year's budget
the point is that no matter how many
veterans come forward ten or ten
thousand the funds will always be there
but Kim and Blair Davis say many vets
have to fight for those funds and
services but I'm gonna stop until every
family is taken care of because it's
about all the families
michael--ah creature global news Ottawa
still ahead a deadly pipeline Inferno in
Nigeria that's far from the first
firefighters in Nigeria tried to quell
the flames of a deadly pipeline
explosion in Lagos at least 15 people
were killed and about 50 buildings were
destroyed in the resulting fire if not
yet known what caused the blast but
pipeline explosions are common
throughout Nigeria they're usually
connected to oil thieves the köppen 19
crisis is delaying the corruption trial
for Israel's Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu's trial was scheduled to start
on Tuesday but it has now been postponed
for two months due to developments
related to the spread of coronavirus
Netanyahu is facing several charges
including bribery breach of trust and
fraud he denies all of them he is
Israel's longest-serving leader and
opponents are accusing him of exploiting
the pandemic in an attempt to hold on to
power the country has had three
inconclusive elections in less than a
year and today Netanyahu's main
political rival been against one support
from Israel's Arab coalition to form
government up next after escaping the
despair of sex trafficking three women
share their stories if the clandestine
crime victims are abused often become
addicted to drugs and they're afraid to
break free but some do and tonight in
part two of our series we're getting a
rare glimpse inside sex trafficking in
Canada Jamie Dahl spoke with free
survivors and has more on their story
you have this opinion option of well
this is what you're gonna do or you're
gonna die abused addicted and sold for
sex not so long ago Rene Serra and Lewis
not their real names we're living that
nightmare how big of a problem is this
bigger than you think yep they say the
people paying can include men women
couples most of the ones that I have
come through my life have been married
any families Lewis says she wants me
$25,000 in one night all the money I
made was going to the guy his child
support was going to his car payments
going to our rent the abuse and things
just got worse and worse and he'd still
make me work so why not leave why not
try to escape he constantly threatened
me he scared me more than anything and
losing my house scared me and being
homeless again scared me and I was told
that 5/6 time they ever gonna kill me
are they were gonna kill my parents if I
didn't do what I was told so that's why
I went along with everything as much as
I didn't want to over spirit for my life
for my family but the day didn't chew
elique um for all three of these women
when they decided enough was enough I
was looking in the mirror with my nose
bleeding and like I was just sick of
myself I was just really sick of me
finally I just turned myself in to the
homeless shelter and then my counselor
suggested reset reset is the only full
year program of its kind in Canada
dedicated to helping victims of sexual
exploitation and trafficking the girls
move into homes with other survivors are
protected go to class taught life skills
and get sober the longer they're here
they start planning their future and
they're there dreaming we have a lotta
loft in the class there's a lot of Tears
and it's not just the women they help
but their children too we see such a
change from the wee little guys when
they come in and you know a lot of them
are broken - they've they've they've
lived that lifestyle they've they've
seen the violence and the trauma these
women who are more than halfway through
credit the program The Sisterhood for
saving their lives I finally feel safe
and I feel free and
I don't have to look over my shoulder
anymore
Rene who arrived here homeless seven
months pregnant and battling a heroin
addiction had her baby with her reset
caseworker by her side it's um made me
into the woman I should be it's changed
me a hundred percent Luis is sober and
now wants to go into Social Work it all
goes back to that whole will love you
till you can love yourself thing you
know we all fight for each other just as
much for ourselves do you feel you could
go back to that you know I feel like not
by choice but I feel like it could
happen again but now I just can see the
signs and know if I'm heading in that
direction again Jamie tall global news
Calgary that is global national for this
Sunday I'm Robin Gill
tonight your Canada is Comox on
Vancouver Island thank you for watching
have a great night
[Music]
you